what began in the UK a year ago has gone
global with simultaneous protests taking
place in the name of extinction
rebellion as far afield as Australia New
Zealand and in the capitals of Western
Europe but the climate and environmental
movements spiritual home is central
London where its campaigns of civil
disobedience have caused major
disruption before this time activists
plan to spend the next two weeks defying
the police blockading roads and bridges
leading to the heart of government power
tied up like this we're in the middle of
an emergency there hands glued together
and also stuck to the tarmac this group
were all under arrest but unable to be
dislodged from outside the Prime
Minister's residence at number 10
Downing Street I agree with the sanction
rebellion three aims which are that the
government declares an emergency but
also acts on its that they bring down
the carbon levels to zero by 2025 that
they stop the diet biodiversity loss
that the whole planet is suffering at
the moment
others were cut free from chains binding
them to cars to railings and to each
other when extinction rebellion carried
out similar protests in April the police
were criticized for being too tolerant
this time the force has promised to be
more proactive but controlling dozens of
often autonomous individual protests is
an enormous task fewer than 50 people
manning this protest barricade blocking
off Whitehall that's the road leading to
10 Downing Street it's a sign of just
how easy it is to cause major disruption
and with thousands more said to be ready
to do this very thing it's a sign of how
difficult it is to police
this was the scene during the day in
Cape Town South Africa it doesn't matter
what party you come from we're all in
those planets and we all threatened by
the extinction and we must stand
together so anyway you're going to get
through and this was Amsterdam where
police made dozens of arrests in London
it was a quiet day for anti brexit
protesters the focus for once elsewhere
but extinction rebellion activists
intend to be here till the end of next
week including the Queen's speech in
Parliament next Monday
the police are unlikely to tolerate that
Jonah hull al Jazeera London